beauty expert and youtube star nick
chapman was diagnosed with ms a few
years ago last month she took the
decision to fly to mexico for a new
treatment that isn't available on the
nhs at nick is with us now hello
hello
tell me more tell me about the treatment
so um there's a treatment for ms called
hsct it's the same treatment that selma
blair had recently
and i've had ms for
10 plus years but in the last couple of
years
i noticed it was getting a lot worse
ms is multiple sclerosis and it's a
disease and illness which stops the
neurological pathways from going from
your brain to different parts of your
body so it stops the signal going there
so it's very debilitating and everyone
has ms in a different kind of way
um i looked into having hsct done in the
uk
and it's impossible unless you go
privately and it is just so ridiculously
expensive
in this country to have it done so i
took the option to fly to mexico to have
the treatment done because mexico and
russia are the leaders in this treatment
and what does the treatment involve
um you have
about four or five rounds of
chemotherapy to
kill off the active ms that's in your
body and then they
take your stem cells give you more chemo
to kill off what's left there that isn't
working properly and reboot your immune
system and then they give you your stem
cells back hoping that no longer your
body will remember that it was fighting
itself
so
is this like a cure for ms then
they can't say cure but it has an 80
success rate and it's in its infancy so
although
mexico have been doing it for 10 15
years
they don't know the full outcome but for
me it has an 80 chance of working and
it's
saves me having to take drugs for the
rest of my life if this works then my ms
will be halted i will stay where i am
now which is still mobile and still
slight
cognitively
able
not always but um it will mean that my
ms won't get any worse and i just really
want to try and raise awareness for this
to try and also get neurologists in this
country to know a little bit more about
it so that they when people who are
living with ms like me go in to see
their neurologist they don't feel like
they're just getting completely purposed
about something that is such a brilliant
um hopefully life-changing treatment
yeah because when you think about ms you
think oh you know the brits or the
americans are going to be world leaders
on treatments not the russians and the
mexicans
yeah it's very very true um and
we do have the treatment here and
actually the drugs that are given to us
in the uk which is amazing i don't want
to um be against drugs because they work
so brilliantly for so many people
um but there is another thing that is
groundbreaking and it's actually much
cheaper for the nhs than the drugs that
people are living on so the drugs that
are offered to you
are brilliant and work for some people
but they can cost sixty thousand pounds
a year whereas people living with ms
could have this treatment done and it
only costs the nhs forty thousand pounds
for the treatment and they may never
have to take drugs again
so why do you think we don't do that
i don't i don't i honestly don't know
i'm trying to look into it because you
can do have it done privately
but there's a lot of people that can't
afford that because in this country it
costs about 100 000 pounds to have it
done privately
um
i think the knowledge probably isn't
there it's already done for
leukemia
um i also think that probably ms is a
it's slightly different for leukemia but
ms is a long debilitating disease
whereas a lot of the people that do get
stem cells their outcome is quite quick
and fast
so i think they just think we'll just
see whether we can manage it with drugs
for a long time but for someone living
with ms
they don't always have a long time and
that that downfall is just
horrific to
notice changes in your body every day
and
brain that doesn't work all the time and
not being able to play with your
children it's um
it's a long slow
illness which is just heartbreaking so i
wish that they would and that's why i'm
trying to talk out as much as i can
about hsct to try and
get neurologists to know a little bit
more about it and not be so scared of it
and to get people living with ms and
people in general to understand ms and
know about this treatment
so what happens next then nick
um
i am
as you can see i am only a couple of
months back i'm now starting to get a
little bit of energy back and um
feeling really good but it's going to be
a long roller coaster i have to have a
couple of mris to see whether my my
lesions are no longer active
um
i feel really good in my body whereas
when i first came back i didn't so much
um
i feel really good and it's brilliant
because there are some people that have
had this treatment like i've reached out
with selma blair and we've spoken a few
times about the treatment and she said
just hang on in there it takes a long
time for it to start to work and there's
an 80 success rate for me so i have
really high hopes for it and that i will
never have to go on
drugs again and i will be able to live
hopefully a drug-free happy healthy life
amazing i mean just before i let you go
how challenging was it going to mexico
because of covid and the fact that of
course that it was on the red route
it was so challenging well when we got
there mexico wasn't on the red list and
as i started my second round of chemo
mexico got put on the red list
and i'm sitting there having chemo and
was like
my husband was like mexico on the red
list i was like well we're too far in
now i don't know what to do so um
it took about a month and finally the
government got back to us to say i'd be
exempt because obviously when you come
back i had no immunity at all and i was
neutropenic so i had i couldn't stay in
a hotel because i had to be so careful
so we were lucky that we managed to make
it home but actually while i was there i
felt incredibly safe because i was in my
own little bubble with no one around
coming home has been more of a challenge
okay look after yourself great to talk
to you keep in touch and let us know how
you get on thank you take care